what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and a few days ago we got our first
look at
marvel's the eternals marvel released a
trailer that had
multiple trailers inside of it including
this teaser trailer so it was a
teaser trailer inside of a trailer
they're in the computer
in the computer and with the few seconds
of the eternals footage that we got we
actually got
some confirmations for a leak that we
got for the entire plot of the eternals
not too long ago
and this plot leak is actually backed
with quite a bit of evidence
including some evidence from the teaser
that we got the other day and from the
teaser trailer that people saw at cc xp
not too long ago
so a good amount if not all of this plot
leak is pretty legitimate
so of course i'll go over the whole
thing and then talk about how i
kind of really don't like one specific
part about it and i think a lot of
people probably won't like it as well
but we'll see
and a reminder i'm still doing my
stormbreaker giveaway all you have to do
to enter subscribe to my channel and my
other channel cosmic culture
details in the description down below so
again like i said
a lot of these parts in this plot leak
have been confirmed to be true by either
the trailer they showed at ccxp
or the trailer that we just recently got
so let's dive into it
start right from the beginning it says
the opening title card will explain the
deviants and the eternals the deviants
were created by the celestials to hunt
predators that prey on intelligent life
on newly evolving worlds but then they
started to hunt life as well
so the celestials created the eternals
to kill the deviants
we then opened 5 000 years ago in
mesopotamia
where a man is fishing on some rocks
with a sun and is attacked by a deviant
from the ocean
the eternal show up and a short battle
commences after which they line up in a
triangular hero pose and this
rolls into the marvel logo opening
jumping to present day
cersei and dane whitman are teachers in
the uk and they are dating
during a class lesson a large earthquake
strikes and sarzi saves a child from a
falling object by turning it
into sand later while out on a date a
deviant attacks cersei sprite and dane
during the battle icarus shows up
and they fight it off after noting that
they thought all the deviants were
destroyed and
unlike others this deviant in particular
was able to heal its own wounds
the group decides to visit ajac as she
was the leader of the group
after arriving at the midwest ranch
where she is now living they discover
her dead body
a small golden device leaves ajax's body
and
enters sarzi this device is how ajax
used to communicate with the celestials
after this they decide to round up the
rest of the eternals to deal with the
deviant threat
fina and gilgamesh are in australia and
due to an issue with her memory
she randomly attacks the other eternals
it says that gilgamesh
is obviously in love with theena but
this is not played as a romantic
relationship in the movie
fastos lives with his husband and their
child but he decides to help due to the
fact that he has fully embraced the
human race and wants to protect his
family
makari has been living in the eternal's
ship all this time
kingo is a bollywood actor in which
there's a short dance routine that
introduces him
and he comes with the group along with
his valet who tries to document
everything on video and if you recall
this is actually a scene that we saw in
the eternals teaser
king go is kamil nanjiani and in one of
the scenes we saw him
looking off into the distance and we did
see his valet with a camera in his hand
jewig is living in some rainforest
controlling a small village of people
after losing faith in humanity and
wanting to control them to stop
war famine etc during this scene the
deviants attacked the eternals and
gilgamesh is killed fighting the
deviants in the forest
sarzi learns that the celestials
actually created both
races the eternals and the deviants and
that the celestials are basically just
very advanced robots they seed young
planets with the celestial egg that
takes eons to mature
the evolving intelligent life on these
planets feeds the celestial's growth
so the eternals are sent to protect the
evolving life forms and kill the
deviants
however after the emergence of the
celestial egg the eternals are rebooted
and then they are sent to another world
and this is what is causing dina's
memory issue as she knows that the
planet is doomed this cycle has gone on
for millions
of years earth was seeded and tayamat is
about to emerge
this was actually the cause of the
earthquake earlier once awakened the
celestial will destroy the entire planet
and all of the life
on it after learning this the eternals
debate on what to do
and some decide to try and find a way to
stop the emergence
icarus disagrees sprite and kingo are on
his side but kingo agrees to help
fastos designs a device the uni mind
that will allow druid to channel
all of the eternals energy in the hope
of controlling tayamat and putting him
back to sleep
cersei learns that icarus actually knew
about the celestial's actual plan and
this is why he left the group hundreds
of years ago
he killed ajac because she had decided
to help stop the emergence and save
earth the group goes to where tayamat is
and attempts to use the device
but icarus and sprite try to stop them
cersei then uses the device to amplify
her own powers and turn tayama to marble
just as his hand and part of his head
is emerging from the indian ocean after
this icarus flies off
into space towards the sun and it's
unclear if he just
left or if he flew into the sun and
killed himself
then cersei makes sprite a real human
with what remains of her powers
a few days later athena makari and druid
leave in the ship to seek out other
eternals and try to stop the cycle of
destruction
cersei kingo and fasto stay on earth but
are then pulled into space by arishum
and vanish the plot leak then goes on to
talk about what the two post-credit
scenes could be
and according to this plot leak here's
what they are the first one
is dane looking at an old box and he
pulls out a sword that is wrapped up
just as he is about to touch it an
off-screen voice stops him
this is obviously a setup for him to
become his comic book character
the black knight and the sword that he
could be discovering is the ebony blade
a blade that had been carved from a
meteor and enchanted by the wizard
merlin it was originally made for the
first black knight sir percy of scandia
who is an ancestor of dane whitman's
the second post credit scene is on the
eternals ship
pip the troll appears and introduces
star fox
now for those of you who don't know star
fox is an eternal and is actually the
brother of
thanos thanos is actually an eternal he
was born of two eternal parents but he
inherited the deviant gene which is why
he is insanely strong
and since the eternals and deviants are
essentially immortal
i figured it was only a matter of time
until thanos's brother star fox actually
appeared
so that's the plot leak but there are a
few main points that we have to talk
about here
the one main point i want to talk about
which is the main point that i really
really don't like
is the fact that ajax dies and is
actually killed by icarus
to me i'm not sure this would make sense
icarus is a good guy in the comics and
one of his main
priorities in the comics is actually
looking after his eternal family so to
make him sort of a bad guy in this
i really don't like that especially the
fact that he would kill off ajak which
is salma hayek's character
it would be such a waste to have her in
the mcu for only a brief moment
now the problem here is that this league
talked about her settling
in a midwest ranch in which we just saw
in the trailer that that
is the case she was on a horse wearing a
cowboy hat
on a ranch and this leak came out a
while ago so this is
probably true which makes me pretty mad
that's a complete waste of salma hayek
but hopefully it could be wrong however
there are many parts of this plot leak
that are true
for example it says that sarsi and dane
whitman are teachers in the uk
and that they're dating and we've
actually seen leaked pictures of this
we've actually seen cersei and dane
whitman kissing
another part that is true is fastest
will live with his husband
and their child marvel studios has
already confirmed that one of the
eternals will be gay
specifically fast dose and as you can
see here in the plot league
that is another thing that's true and
then of course kingo being a bollywood
actor comes as no surprise kamil
nanjiani recently
opened up about how he had to learn this
whole dance sequence for the movie
so another true part and then last but
not least the druid is living in some
rainforest scene seems to be true
as well and this actually explains one
random scene that we got in the little
teaser where we see
most of the eternals together and in the
background are a bunch of people dressed
in white
it is actually kind of creepy but the
fact that druid has lost faith in
humanity and is wanting to control
humanity to stop
war and famine and etc this scene makes
sense
this could be the village that he's
living in and these people could be the
people that he's trying to control
so overall this plot leak seems fairly
accurate which kind of makes me mad
because i don't want ajax to die within
the first couple minutes of the movie
and i also don't want icarus to be bad
so it is possible that
some parts are right of this plot leak
and maybe some other parts aren't but
that could just be wishful thinking on
my part
but let me know what you think about
this in the comments down below what
would you think of this
eternals story plot would you enjoy this
or does this make you mad as well
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to
subscribe to stay up to date on all of
the latest mcu news
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you